das sind die Zahlen wie sagt das RKI
derzeit ein unvollständiges Bild
abliefern das sind aber auch die Zahlen
an denen sich die Maßnahmen der Politik
orientieren müssen wir darüber sprechen
mit unseren Chef mit Jan Schäfer bei uns
im Studio bei Bild live also das sind
die Zahlen mit denen auch wir heute früh
arbeiten müssen besser haben wir leider
nicht bekommen dazu heute früh weiter
hinter Hinweis sowie ein Patricia ist
gerade gesagt hat auf der Seite des
Robert-Koch-Instituts na moment mal die
Zahlen sind immer noch unvollständig der
Stand vom 30 December da waren ja jetzt
schon paar Tage und nicht nur Feiertage
dazwischen wie kann das sein und was
muss die Politik jetzt tun um diesen
Missstand endlich zu beheben ja das ist
bemerkenswert Kai du sagst es gerade
dass wir eigentlich in der gleichen
Situation sind in der wie im vergangenen
Jahr auch gewesen sind da hatten wir das
gleiche Problem auch damals 20/20 Ende
20/20 hat das Robert-Koch-Institut
gewarnt und gesagt über die Feiertage
werden wir nicht so gut erheben können
uns wird eine Zeitverschiebung geben
ungefähr Mitte Januar bis die Zahlen
wieder richtig valide sind und wir sehen
das gleiche jetzt auch wieder unter der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
ja kurz vor Silvester in Bild auch vor
einem Corona Blindflug gewahrt und hat
gesagt die Zahlen die wir erheben die
sind nicht vollständig und deswegen die
Frage wieso sind sie nicht vollständig
wieso wurde eigentlich 12 Monate lang
nichts getan so überraschend kommt
Weihnachten nicht überraschend kommt
Silvester auch nicht also warum ist
nicht die Vorsorge getroffen worden um
am kommenden Freitag wenn die Länder und
der Bund wieder zusammenkommen eine
Datenbasis zu haben einzahlen Pool der
wirklich valide ist um dann entscheiden
zu können wie es weitergeht wir hören
das Wort Lockdown bereits wieder aus
einige Länder das heißt es wird auch am
Freitag um die Frage gehen brauchen wir
Lockdown Maßnahmen neue Lockdown
Maßnahmen aber offenbar auf einer
Datenbasis die nicht valide ist und das
ist nicht in Ordnung
Förderung du sagst es genauso wie im
letzten Jahr und dennoch stehen so
wichtige Entscheidungen an heute Kern in
vielen Bundesländern die Schülerin und
Schüler zurück in die Schule wenn alle
getestet also da werden wir relativ
schnell Zahlen haben wie es aussieht bei
den Kindern auch in der Kita ist die zum
Teil eben noch gar nicht geimpft werden
können wie geht man mit diesen Zahlen
dann um und macht es aus deiner Sicht
überhaupt Sinn sich dann jetzt zusammen
zu setzen und Maßnahmen zu beschließen
die man wahrscheinlich Tage später wenn
dann aktuelle Zahlen endlich vorliegen
wieder widerrufen oder zumindest
nachschärfen muss also dem Trend die
Inzidenz wenn man sich an der
orientieren mag dann geht die Inzidenz
er wieder nach oben wie sehen bei den
Fallzahlen einen völlig diffuses Bild
eigentlich auch bei der Hospitalisierung
das Bild haben wir gerade gesehen der
Westen komplett grün also unter der
Marke von drei das heißt es ist gar
nicht richtig klar was da derzeit
eigentlich passiert wir haben von einer
Omikron Wand gehört die sich zu
Jahresbeginn auf tun soll also steil
nach oben geht was die Infizierten nein
angeht die sehen wir derzeit nicht und
deswegen ist das ganze was wir sehen
eigentlich eine Blamage für die Politik
einen Corona gibt für durchzuführen mit
nicht validen zahlen und eigentlich
müsste dieser Gipfel verschoben werden
nämlich bis zu einem Zeitpunkt an dem es
ganz klare Daten gibt das eine
verschieben gibt's diese Diskussion
Ministerpräsidenten
Schleswig-Holstein
eine Frage die sich mir stellt ist warum
ist eigentlich bei uns nicht möglich was
in Großbritannien möglich ist dort
umgeht man diese Problematik an
Feiertagen beispielsweise dass man ganz
anders Mist war eine Grundgesamtheit und
für Deutschland könnte man sagen wenn
sich 30.000 40.000 Einwohner und nimmt
anhand dieser Grundgesamtheiten ist also
dort gibt es Omikron Fälle wie ist die
Infizierten Entwicklung und rechnet das
dann hoch das heißt weite diese
Feiertags Problematik gar nicht so ein
ziemlich genaues Bild eigentlich wohl
ein genaueres über das was wirklich in
Deutschland passiert da ist ganz klar
geschlafen worden das geschlampt worden
also wir steuern wieder in einen
Blindflug Lockdown oder darüber
überhaupt gesprochen
wir letztes Jahr wir haben jetzt alle
nicht was machen wir da oder sind
einfach ein gesteuert also wenn wir das
letzte Jahr Revue passieren lassen dann
hatten wir genau diese diese Problematik
nicht nur zum Jahreswechsel sondern auch
über die Osterfeiertage beispielsweise
also dann ja auch um die Debatte Bundes
Lockdown gehen wir haben das immer
wieder erlebt auch an dem Wochenende 3.
Oktober das ist mit Zeitverzögerung
Meldung erst gab und von daher bleibt
schon die Frage warum hat euch der
Bundesgesundheitsminister warum haben
andere Gesundheitspolitiker
beispielsweise auch der neue
Bundesgesundheitsminister Karl
Lauterbach nicht darauf gedrungen
zuschauen wie können wir entweder die
Gesundheitsämter viel besser aufstellen
für diese Feiertage oder B ein ganz
anderes Modell ausprobieren mich dass
die wir es beispielsweise in
Großbritannien sehen 12 Monate haben wir
darüber diskutiert haben die Probleme
auch gesehen passiert es leider nichts